all right crystal mm-hmm
crystal where'd you grow up where are
you from originally um i was born in san
pedro california
you stayed in california yeah i was born
in san pedro um and then when i was a
couple months old my family moved to
cherry hill new jersey
and then um i stayed there until
i think preschool
and my mom um she went to daycare in new
jersey
and i was in the daycare
and um she ran that from home and my dad
worked
and then um my dad got another job offer
uh in las vegas so
we moved to vegas and while she was in
jersey too she also had my brother
um
when i was three
and then we moved to vegas
and i went to school up there until the
middle fourth grade and then we moved
back to um california to orange county
and how would you describe your
childhood in general
um i was
quiet
um i was a quiet kid but i loved animals
and um
i kind of made them my friends uh
um
i was
i was mostly by my uncle when i was
younger
and um
i think that's why i gravitated towards
animals so much
because i kind of like
internalized all of that and um
i didn't really talk about it
um
and then when i did talk about my mom
immediately took my uncle out of the
picture
um from our home and everything from
watching me and my brother and um
but it still kind of
[ __ ] me up a little bit
because he was like the
when my dad was away he was kind of like
the father figure
so
i i didn't have that anymore
and even though he did what he did
i um
i
you know i cared about him
and it was it was kind of like a weird
position for me to be in because i loved
him but you know he hurt me at the same
time so i almost feel like i kind of
became two separate people
like i
i had one side that was like the victim
and then the other side i just pretended
it didn't happen
um so i could just go forward and um
i think i
i kind of um
worked through my emotions with my pets
i um
i would catch lizards and stuff and um
i just i made them like my family i
guess it's kind of weird
to say that but um how old were you when
this happened i was
uh
i believe like
about four five or six about um did you
go on for a while or uh about a year or
two between one and two years um
but uh
i just i didn't know it was wrong i just
knew it felt wrong and um i remember i
even wrote a letter to jesus
um
you know asking for help uh but i i hid
it i hid it underneath my mattress and
then
one day i went to go look for it and it
disappeared so i don't know if who had
found it or if it was found if it
just got lost when she was you know
washing the bedding
but um i had my grandmother watching us
my mom's mom my uncle and then my
grandma's sister um who was one of two
twins and uh
they um they would take us to and from
school
and while my mom worked for a judge in
vegas
and she um
you know she was a good mom and she
still is
um i i don't blame her for any of the
stuff that happened i didn't tell her
and um she she cried you know and um got
upset when i told her and as did the
rest of my family venue
and um i know she was doing the best she
could and she still was able to provide
like
a home for me and my brother and pay the
mortgage so i'm proud of her you know um
as a mom myself now
um
you know i know that's that's a really
hard job
and
we can't you know judge each other
constantly like
and we just have to support each other
so you know i love my mom even if we
have our differences which we do
um i love her and i'm grateful that she
tried you know her best
you know it just feels i feel like it's
important for me to say that because i
don't want her to um
think that i blame her because i don't
what kind of kid were you in high school
i was a dork i was um really shy i was
in uh rotc
which is a reserve officer training
corps
for the navy
and um i had to wear like a uniform
every wednesday and i had big boots
and i was in the drill team um i worked
with the rifles but they weren't loaded
and they were like antique i think and
we would throw them up in the air and
march and do all these like kind of
tricks with them
um but it was kind of crazy for me to do
that because i'm i'm a little bit of a
klutz like i'm the person that like runs
into stuff all the time and
i'm just
uh yeah i'm not athletic like my brother
i'm the polar opposite so um
i i did it because i thought it would
look good on my college application
which i didn't even
end up applying for i just went to a jc
out of high school
and drugs started for you at some point
yeah and probably out of high school um
i mean i drank in high school like at
parties and stuff
but um
i i was raped when i was 16
um
and that that's probably when i started
really drink um
i
i didn't i told a few people when it
happened but the people i did tell kind
of um
some of them i felt like blame me
and um
they
they i didn't get the understanding that
i thought i would and so i didn't really
tell many people
and um it [ __ ] me up like i i broke up
with my boyfriend that i was seeing at
the time
because he couldn't handle it you know
hearing about it just put a strain on a
relationship and um
i i feel like it was like a pivotal
moment in
in my upbringing because i
i stopped trying so hard in school
um
it just
they took something from me i felt like
that i never got back and um
it messed me up a lot
and i i
partied harder
when it happened and um i would just
drink to get wasted
to like escape that
um so alcohol i guess was my first drug
and then um
in my early 20s i think i tried meth for
the first time
and i remember when i first tried it it
was amazing like i felt like euphoria
and happy
but then every time after that it just
kind of was a mediocre high but um
i think it was more like the atmosphere
that you know the people
you know talking to and you just you
know
you just get used to it
sort of and um you slip into an
addiction
very fast
and um
i stopped doing it
for a long time and then um
recently
uh when i lost my kids and everything um
you know i i got into it again because i
didn't feel like there was hope
and um
it just yeah it was hard
how many kids do you know i have four
and four
and where are they now um they're with
their fathers
they're their dads
and um
i miss them every day my mom my mom
watches them too um and if i didn't have
her i'd be i'd be upset
but um i know she's a wonderful she's a
great mom to me and she's a great
grandma to them and um
i yeah i
have no words for like
how grateful i am to her for doing that
and i know they're safe with her
but um
i don't think there's any
um replacement for a mom
you know even if it is a grandma so
uh
in the future i don't know exactly when
when i get my [ __ ] together i want to
go back to them you know i know it's
going to be a hard road though
a really hard road and um
there's some things that happen to me
while out on the streets
that um i kind of want closure for
before i feel safe enough to return to
them um i was raped again two more times
two more times out here
and um i feel like like the rapist like
um
might come after my kids
and in retaliation
i'm scared
um
i never thought that it would happen to
me again
and when it did you just say [ __ ] me
up
and um
one of the guys
um beat me really bad
i gave me a black eye and i think you
fractured my nose um i didn't report
either of them for fear of retaliation
and um
because i was i was scared and i didn't
have a rape kit for either time so i
felt like the chances of
any type of prosecution would fail
and um
your
so i just i've been living with that
like and every time i see someone who
slightly resembles them
i
just like
i
they kind of stop breathing almost and
um i start to panic and you could like
if you were looking at me you would see
like fear
um one of the guys was really big
a large in stature and um
he could have broken me like a tweet he
was the one that he he beat me up really
bad i was bleeding
um
and the other guy was a white guy and uh
it happened down by the riverbed and he
used someone's name
that i knew he said that they were there
hurt injured in the tent and for me to
come with them so just like as any
because of being a parent you know if
someone says they're hurt
you just instantly go you don't even
think and that's what i did you know i
just thought okay someone's heard that i
care about i'm gonna go to him
and make sure he's all right and i
followed this dude and he kept on
changing his kind of story as we got
further and further away from where i
was at where it was safe
and then we get there the guy's not
there that he said was there
and um and he was high he was smoking a
lot of crystal which i didn't realize at
first
and um the tent was like a mess
and i see two guns and um one of them he
put at my temple and he pulled the
trigger
and um
i remember being so [ __ ] scared like
thinking he's gonna kill me
and um
i don't i believe there was a bully in
the chamber but it didn't
it didn't fire on the shot that he
pulled with me
so it's kind of like roulette i guess
and um
he said if
if i don't comply and do what he says
those weren't exact words that he was
gonna you know kill me
and so i had to just lay there when he
did what he did and it um
i remember just crying
saying please don't
and just um there was a guy in the tent
right outside and i thought if if i say
anything
he'll kill me and i'll kill that guy
because he's a witness and they'll never
find our bodies nor will they hear it
because we're right by the freeway with
all the cars going by it was very loud
like i thought about all this
before i decided i couldn't do anything
but um
as soon as we got out
as soon as he was done
i said i immediately stopped crying
i got my head together and i said um
i i'm really hungry i'm really hungry
and he um he goes oh you are and he he
was so crazy he just went along with it
and um thank you
and
he goes well let's go get something yeah
i go yeah i think there's a taco truck
because i remember seeing one on the way
in it was a rick's taco truck
and um
as soon as we hit the the main highway
or whatever
i [ __ ] ran i broke away from him i
ran like my life depended on it and i
didn't look back at the whole time i was
like i'm trying not to duck like i felt
like he was gonna shoot me from the
heart but he didn't and i ran so far and
so fast and i heard him yelling
something
but i ignored it and i kept on going and
then i zigzagged through buildings and
stuff and got away from them and
a couple months after
a guy did approach me on the street that
i believed was him but
he had changed his appearance so much i
i didn't quite recognize him and he
tried to give me a bike or bicycle
um
and i told him to get him and i said you
and the bike can go [ __ ] yourselves and
like if you you know get near me again
i'm gonna shove you in the intersection
and um
he
like kind of acted weird and then he
left and um before that when he did rape
me he did try to give me a bicycle then
too it was a brand new one a new pink
one
like metallic pink and um i thought that
was really weird like
i don't know why someone would raise one
and then give him a bicycle after to
ride like who would want to ride a
bicycle like a rate bike was just
[ __ ] weird
and
[Music]
uh
it [ __ ] me up though and i've been so
scared after
this all happened because i feel like he
had a shirt that's a google on it and i
feel like there's a connect that
maybe like he thought because i hung out
with some biker guys before that
in a different house in van nuys and i
thought that maybe he thought i was a
biker or something which i'm not
but i feel like it was like a mistaken
identity or like it was retaliation or
something
for
some misunderstanding
so i've been really scared ever since to
talk about her to do anything because i
feel like
he he knew that i was hanging out with
that guy that he had mentioned so that
meant he had eyes on me days before that
when i thought at a time when i thought
i was alone
so
i you know i was piecing together all
these things in my head about what he
knew about me and it scared the [ __ ] out
of me because
i never saw him you know i don't know
where he was following us how he was
tracking me
um the only thing i could think is the
obama phone i had i believe at the time
um that was the only device on me but
still
how did he connect to that i don't know
and um
i remember being an uber or something
later on and i saw him at a gas station
he was really drunk but he didn't see me
and i just i stayed in the car and i hid
and i haven't seen him since but i've
been scared about it ever since
because the person that um
that i hung out with before that
i later learned to be an la county
sheriff department member he um the guy
he used to bait me in the tent he gave
me a street name which i won't use just
in case um someone tries to hurt him
but he didn't give me his real name and
he was dressed in plain clothes but
later on i see him jump into a squad car
and
that really startled me it's like why is
there a cop
or a police officer um
like hanging out with me in this this
this place
you know and then how does that guy know
that i did hang out with him and why is
he using his name to bait me in there
like it was just really weird
and it scared me to the point where i
feel like i can't even go to them
because they're part of it you know like
they
like it's all they they're already
involved like i'll put myself in so much
change or like if i say anything so
i couldn't and then
um
once down the road i was walking again
and i was so tired
and someone pulls up and they go do you
need a ride somewhere and it was
a black dude and i said
yeah because i literally i thought he
was just gonna give me mine i didn't
think he would hurt me
like stupidly
um i was so exhausted like beyond belief
and i get in the car and go a gas
station he gets a cigar
and he's acting really calm and cool
whatever and i'm just so grateful to be
off my feet
and then he goes do you want some holi
and i didn't know what the [ __ ] holly
was
and i thought it meant like the secret
so i said yeah and he busted this the
cigar whatever i i said
oh no it's okay
and then he proceeds to drive somewhere
else from where i said
and he goes i go wait where are you
going you're going the wrong way he goes
oh well
um i just have to go my house real quick
i'm like oh no and i kind of had a
sinking feeling like this isn't going
good because every time someone's done
that to me like
things just go wrong
when they um divert from the agenda
and um we get there and i forget what
the reason was but he gets me to go
inside the house like he didn't want me
wait in the car he said something about
the neighbors or something
and i get in there and then he um
he throws me on the bed or he pushes me
i was sitting on the edge of the bed
because it was like a studio like a
one-room place i'm seeing the edgy
pushes me down
and um
he gets on top of me and starts and i
say no no no and
he starts beating me up
makes my nose bloody and it gives me a
black eye and he punched me probably
like 15 times
and i thought he was gonna kill me i
just i remember like almost choking on
my blood
and i'm thinking oh my god i'm gonna die
i'm gonna die
if i can't die i haven't seen my kids
like
this isn't happening
and um
i
he
he rapes me
and um
when i was over
i i was just laying there and
i he was put your [ __ ] clothes on
real quick or something i thought he was
gonna shoot me and because he had also
said during the rape he said if you um
if you if you do anything i'm gonna
shoot you because i have a gun in that
bag any emotion like towards the corner
and i never actually saw a gun
but he said he had one and he had um
i remember hanging up or something and
allied securities
uh black jacket with the patch on this
the sleeve
and so i assumed like that he worked for
them
and i thought that was pretty stupid of
him to keep that
out you know because he's letting me
know where he works
but um
somehow i got brave and i got him to i
go
he asked me where i live and i i
couldn't i was kind of [ __ ] up from
him hitting me in the head i couldn't
articulate exactly where i lived and he
was getting impatient so he asked me the
address because he was going to put it
in his app
in his phone
and i'm again i'm thinking this guy is
[ __ ] stupid like why would he do that
like that's you know that could be used
against him but
i said it i gave him an address he put
it in his phone and he drove me to i
asked him to go to my mom's house
because i could not think of any other
address right then um
and i didn't want him to kill me
with him being so impatient
so he puts it in and when we drive to my
mom's house i start
meaning and just so you know me my mom
hadn't talked for a while before this so
it wasn't normal for me to just show up
like that so i thought that alone would
get my mom or some of my family to
realize something was wrong you know and
get help
but it didn't work out that way i pull
up and
he goes get out of the car and i start
throwing stuff um out of his car to make
a scene so hopefully the neighbors or
someone would see and like do something
and um
it didn't hap nothing happened like i
threw the stuff out then he got mad and
i believe he got out picked it up and
put it back in there and i ran to the
door and he speeds off
and there's a woman named
who i was told his name cindy answers
the door and mind you
my mom has a friend named cindy who's a
hairdresser
but this was not that cindy and i
thought that's really [ __ ] weird like
who is this woman i've never seen her
before and she was like directing my mom
and telling my mom what to do like
oh don't let her in like it was as if
they were prepared for me to be there
and i couldn't for the life of me figure
out how they knew
how like i was coming
and um my mom looked scared her eyes
were like bloodshot like she had been
crying
and um
i immediately felt sick like i felt like
something had simultaneously been going
on in my mom's house when this had been
happening to me you know
and um
the lady goes i you know don't go in the
bathroom don't learn
um she's telling my mom not to let me in
but i i pushed past the lady i go in the
back of my pee i flush the toilet
and um i locked the door when i peed but
they were trying to get in and i thought
that's really [ __ ] weird that they
don't want me to come in something's
wrong but again i've been hit in the
head so i was like out of it
and um i purposely peed because i knew
that they could use that to gain access
into the house you know to figure out
what was wrong with a warrant you know
um
for the dna evidence right they could
they could get a warrant with that i
thought
and um
you know i was just trying to think how
my mom taught me growing up like
what to do in situations that are bad
you know always
think you know use your brain use
everything you know to get out of that
situation because you're your best um
rescuer you know that's what my mom
taught me and so i was just trying to
follow suit
and um i go to the bathroom and uh i
come out and
while i was in there they call the cops
on me
and the cops end up coming and they
arrest me for like trespassing or
something
and i just thought that was so wrong and
then i get there
and i'm still covered in blood my two is
like all over me it's obvious i was hurt
the cops
they take my information in the intake
part of it and then they um i forgot
what what station it was
but we were in west garden grove at my
mom's house
and um
they would take me in and they would you
have anything to report and i said no
and
um
because i was scared of them
and they were so angry when they said it
and then they let release me without
shoes i didn't i left the black leather
size eight shoes at the um
the guy's house because he he was
rushing me too fast and i couldn't find
them but they would have had blood on
them
from me
and uh they released me with no shoes
and i ended up wandering the streets for
a couple days and i forgot exactly where
i think i went to a friend's house
after that
but um
it just it [ __ ] me up a lot and um
i've been scared about like getting cars
ever since and uh
trusting people and
it um
i'll never feel the same again about a
lot of things
and every time i see someone who
remotely resembles them i like i want to
run the other way
and i'm so scared that now that he knows
where my mom lives like there's gonna be
they're in danger and like and like i
can't i tried to go back to my mom's
house to talk and i couldn't get
i couldn't get past like the family
security like other family members they
they wouldn't let me talk to my mom
so it's like something weird is going on
that i i feel like they're not telling
me about
and um
it scares the [ __ ] out of me but i my
hands are tied like i can't communicate
with my family
and i try calling old numbers that i
remember and i can't get through
and um
i don't know what the [ __ ] happened and
why they reacted with no reaction like
why it didn't matter
um
it really hurts to feel like your family
doesn't care enough this was how long
ago
um
frank over
god i don't even know like
a year ago over a year ago
you've been on the streets since then
yeah
i feel like there's a certain level of
safety with um
[Music]
with people that
don't have an address
you know you can't really find on paper
more than a house because the house you
could just go in the computer look up
okay she lives here let me go there if
you're on the street you could be
anywhere so you're hiding by living on
the streets a little bit yeah i didn't
realize i was until i really thought
about it i'm like i'm doing it kind of
for protection because i don't want and
if they're gonna follow me if someone
out there is trying to follow me to hurt
me at retaliation because they think i'm
gonna tell which i wasn't going to
then
i'd rather have them follow me out here
and lead them away from my family and go
to my family so i'm doing it to protect
them
but they don't even know that
it's the worst feeling ever
i could think that like something could
happen to me
and my kids will think i didn't care
about them it'll be the last thought
that mom just left and she's on drugs
and she doesn't care but it's not like
that at all
i love them
and i'm
staying away because i i love them
but it's been really hard it's really
hard to
get happy about things and to
not go to that dark place that it
remembers everything about those days
but um
i do
try to get out of myself and um
when i'm you're not so upset i keep my
eyes out
for other girls
that may be um
led into like a trafficking type
situation or you know become victims of
something similar i always keep my eyes
out for girls like that and if i sense
that they're in some sort of danger i
try to get them away from the group you
know by acting like i'm more friends
than i am and saying let's go you know
let's go get something to eat or
whatever so i can get them to talk
separate from the guys
um
because i think it's a huge problem and
girls are trafficked and
raped more often than we know or talk
about and they're really scared to talk
about it because they'll get beat up or
killed and i've heard about a lot of
bodies lately being found of young women
so um
i'm grateful to be alive but i don't
know for how long i will be
i know i feel like like
it's a ticking
time bomb or something
and um it scares the [ __ ] out of me um
what is your drug now huh what is your
drug now i do fentanyl and crystal
and uppers and downers
how are you supporting yourself
um well for a while i had a boyfriend
but um
we're kind of like
we're unsure right now
so he was um
i would like sometimes clean
uh for extra money and
he he would fly
and um
it's really hard it's really hard to
make make him and meet and
it's
it's a constant struggle
um
and you don't really have even if you do
make money you don't have extra money
you know to have fun to
it's just you're just getting money to
for survival you know the necessities
and that's so hard and it's so hard to
be happy
and um
it it's um
the thing that i found helps is i i talk
to people and i try to
make my own tribe like on the streets
you know like um even though i don't
talk to my family i try to
find family
among them
and
rebuild like
another one you know
and i didn't forget my family but
they're um
it's like they're on hold until i can
figure out what the [ __ ] happened with
all of that and feel secure enough to go
back because i don't want to be followed
like i i really feel like like i was
targeted for some reason
and um
i feel like all these bad things are
connected
and it wasn't just um
you know um random occurrences
and i but without talking to anyone who
who does and looks into stuff like that
i can't be sure
and um
it's it's really scary
i'm always um really aware of men that
like stare at me for too long or
or seem to follow me like
but act really weird or off i i always
spot them right away and
people will be like what's wrong with
you and like i
can't even like talk about it i freeze
up so much but i'll just try to get away
from them
but uh it's hard
it's hard
do you talk with your kids still no i um
my ex he wouldn't uh
he wouldn't allow it
and for a while i was really scared
about their safety
and i would call it he would tell me to
[ __ ] off and hang up the phone on me
and i was just trying to call make sure
they're okay
so finally i i broke the restraining
order that he he placed on the house
which he did just to be vindictive
um
and
i
i went inside and um
i was talking to my daughter
and she was so happy to see me and she
was
she was telling me about a phone she had
gotten and she was so excited and it
just it brought me to tears
it was so heartbreaking and then he
grabbed my eldest son and he pulled him
in the back room and my son is screaming
for me like mommy mommy and
i couldn't go to him because he had him
and then um
within 10 minutes two officers showed up
and they arrested me for trespassing
which i knew they were going to
but
i risked it because i wanted to see my
kids and i wanted i basically did my own
welfare check because they mattered more
to me than getting arrested
and that was the last time i had seen
them
but um i even told my ex about
one of the rapes because it just
happened and he didn't care
he didn't care he said good
so
what do you think people don't
understand about your situation
um
like your family or
i don't think they know what happened or
i think that they're being told
something else
or i feel like maybe
something around me was being watched at
the same time
and maybe they
knew what was happening to me and they
legally couldn't do anything about it so
they feel like if they speak out about
it
they'll be held accountable
i feel like it's a cover-up like they're
they're covering up something else that
was going on
at the same time and if one
if one thing is looked into it's gonna
everything else is gonna be looked into
and kind of like
i don't know like ramparts or whatever
you know
and um
i don't know just some i feel with like
every bone in my body that something
else
happened or it's way bigger than just me
and
i want to speak out about it so bad but
i am i'm so scared of so many things and
people that it's it's not worth it i
feel like i feel like i'll be killed as
like a example and maybe an example
um
and i even tried to find like people
that i dated right before this and i
can't find them
and i'm afraid that something happened
to them
um because of associations they have
or
friends or not friends they have
that may have looked the whole thing as
something other than what it was
and um
another percent tried to find they said
he had a heart attack
and i don't think that's true i feel
like there's more to that than
then i'm hearing and
it just scares me it's like everyone
around it is disappearing
and i'm so scared i'm going to be next
but
every day means more to me than um
than
normal people would uh
probably imagine like i'm grateful for
every day that i'm i'm here
and
i try to make something
you know be seen as like happy
and um i try to appreciate things more
um
it's like my world was black and white
before and now i see color but it's it's
temporary like
i can't um
i don't know how for how long you know
i'll be able to
be okay i feel like i'm just i'm waiting
for something bad to happen again
and it's really hard to live like that
and it's really hard
i don't know what would make me feel
safe though
if they're caught or
i feel like even if they're caught and
they get locked up then they're gonna
blame me you know coming out like i feel
like there's no good
possible outcome
like
perhaps getting away from l.a could be a
good thing for you i don't but then see
i would worry about my kids like
i feel like if i run
away
they're gonna know that that's
what they need to do to scare me and to
keep me
compliant or something like
i'm so scared i'm so tired of running
you know i don't want to run from this
because i want to be
strong for them
and i don't want
my daughter especially to feel like she
she has to fear being a victim ever you
know god forbid something happens to her
which would be my nightmare um
i don't want her to feel like she
doesn't have a platform to speak out
against it
and that's my biggest concern
is raising awareness for other victims
and
giving them a place where they could
comfortably talk about being a victim
because the only way to stop someone
from hurting someone again is for them
to get
reprimanded somehow you know and if we
feel
scared too scared to talk about it
that'll never happen it'll just continue
they'll keep on hurting other people and
it's it's really hard it's really hard
to um
to be brave enough to do that
you know i understand both sides of
other victims stories um you know
telling you're not telling or
it's just really complicated and um
i don't blame anyone either way for
doing what they need to do to be okay
all right crystal thank you so much for
sharing your story
[Music]
yeah i hope you stay safe thank you
you